we begin with the fox news alert the dow
jones industrial is officially now in
negative territory compared to when joe
biden took office now closing below 30
000 the lowest close of biden's
presidency as recession fears now grow
mortgage rates on the rise inflation a
41-year high and the biden price hikes
are as bad as ever and while biden is
dismissing the likelihood of a recession
well the fears on wall street they are
growing louder and louder now all while
consumer spending is now running out of
steam common sense americans they are
continuing to suffer needlessly all
because of joe biden's failing far left
radical economic and anti-fossil fuel
agenda now from gas pump prices to the
grocery aisle 401 k's biden's failures
now are as undeniable as ever as obvious
than ever and frankly as dangerous as
ever so tonight i'm going to start by
asking a couple of very simple and a
couple of very straightforward questions
have you ever seen one president or one
administration fail this much this fast
have you ever seen more incompetence
more bad policy more outright lying than
what we're now seeing from joe biden and
the destructive democratic agenda
literally on a day-to-day basis record
high gas prices 41-year high of
inflation
reckless spending
weak i mean very pathetically weak
diplomacy abroad abandoning our fellow
americans behind enemy lines in the
islamic emirates of afghanistan rising
crime a baby formula shortage relentless
attacks on law enforcement refusing to
condemn supreme court justices and the
doxing of their homes and their families
and their churches a complete
catastrophe at our southern border and a
complete disconnect from reality by the
way
this is only 18 months into his
presidency we got a whopping two and a
half years to go
because while joe biden's administration
tries to cut clout tries to tout their
economic recovery all of you everyday
americans your struggles tell us all a
very very different story doesn't it
take a look
look i i think i was wrong then about
the path that inflation
would take
inflation now running at 8.6 percent the
highest since 1981 and americans are
getting squeezed drivers are frustrated
as the u.s reaches another new record on
gas prices 140 dollars you fill up my
van that's crazy
i'm doing everything in my power
to blunt putin's gas price height this
summer is going to be rough i'll just be
honest with you every time you go and
shop the price of something has gone up
by so much it's insane after a
disastrous report last week showing
prices surging across the entire economy
in my plan for the economy we made
extraordinary progress it's hurting me
it's hurting me bad i don't want to hear
any more of these lies about reckless
spending we're changing people's lives
yeah that's how you get a 32 approval
rating get this new poll from rasmussen
finding that the issues at the top of
minds of independent voters inflation
the economy violent crime the issues
that democrats seem to care
about the least but rather than admit
failure rather than do the sensible
thing reverse course change policy the
biden team they just doubled down on
dumb and dumber and stupid and more
far-left lunacy like attacks on u.s
energy independence and overseeing more
than a doubling of the gas prices from
the trump administration green new deal
socialism attacks on fossil fuels this
is the lifeblood of the world's economy
attacks on our border patrol as now we
have the largest caravan to date are
marching their way right towards the
border attacks on parents why they dare
to stand up to left-wing indoctrination
in schools and talk about
age-appropriate
education for their kids demanding
excellence in teaching when we're
failing them at a spectacular level joey
himself refusing to condemn attacks
against pro-life centers has been a lot
of them the white house's statement this
week was tepid weak pathetic not good
enough joe
and it comes as biden is now continuing
to make one bizarre blunder after
another here's a small sample of joey
your president the past 48 hours
including this comment about a cfo who
recently passed away see if you would
maybe say it the same way
i'm also proud to have signed an
executive order on my first day in
office to combat discrimination against
lgbtql ai excuse me plus
americans and by the way my sympathies
to your the family of your
f
uh
their
your cfo
who uh on drop dead very unexpectedly my
best to their family it's tough stuff
he just dropped that rather unexpectedly
weak frail cognitive wreck out of touch
out to lunch it's even white people like
david axelrod van jones and even don
lemon starting to be honest about it
they were only two years behind me and
this show we were warning everybody
during the campaign it was obvious it
was transparent we were telling people
while he was hiding in his basement
bunker you could still see he was a
cognitive mess and weak and frail and
get this an explosive new piece from the
far left atlantic entitled quote why
biden shouldn't run in 2024. the article
begins quote let me put this bluntly joe
biden should not run for re-election in
2024 he is too old well he's too checked
out it's not about age i listen i think
anybody can give bernie sanders can give
anybody a run for their money he's old
he's not checked out he's not a
cognitive mess anyway the far left media
mob they're being forced to now grapple
with what we have been showing you night
after night trying to warn you about joe
biden is unfit for this office sadly
he's unfit to be the commander-in-chief
and in my opinion that is the toughest
job in the world here's joey earlier
today appearing totally aloof and
ignoring more questions take a look
[Music]
elena
who did business with your son
[Music]
[Music]
at least this time when he turned to
shake somebody's hand there was actually
somebody there now rather than reset
rather than admit failure rather than
change course rather than offer real
solutions biden the democratic party
they just play one blame game after
another they blame so-called big oil
they blame the pandemic they blame putin
they blame republicans they blame
corporations meat companies rich people
and when all else fails just blame
donald trump and by the way don't forget
blame fox news now it gets even better
because speaker pelosi is apparently
trapped in a time warp and is now
blaming all of this
on the war
in iraq take a look
uh with all of the
constraints that covet has played look
we have the worn rock we have covert
which has
really deterred more product coming into
our country
she's not far behind joey you got kamala
one heartbeat away from the presidency
pelosi third in line
god help us let's be clear costs are
rising because of joe biden and the
green new deal climate cultists inside
the new green deal socialist party who
are running the show
joe biden
artificially reduced the world supply of
oil he killed the keystone xl pipeline
he supported burdensome regulations to
make it harder and harder to drill and
to frack he has relentlessly attacked
the u.s oil industry even talking about
sending executives to jail for what for
making money for producing what we need
as a a society to function what is the
world's like the lifeblood of the
world's economy now he's headed to saudi
arabia remember he called saudi arabia
pariah country during the campaign all
while democrats you know overheated the
economy with the so-called american
rescue package that caused even more
massive inflation now they say
that he's not going to beg the crown
prince for to produce more oil they say
that he accused the crown prince of
killing the journalist uh jamal
khashoggi is he going to say it to his
face i tend to doubt it because he wants
saudi oil
americans are struggling to pay their
bills all because of joe biden recession
fears are growing because of joe biden
financial markets are spooked and
tanking because of joe biden inflation
is draining the savings and retirement
funds of americans all across the
country two-thirds of americans now
living paycheck to paycheck because of
joe biden rising gas prices that's a
burden for business that's a burden for
all of us for families all caused by
biden and his new green deal socialist
comrades now add to that a massive
increase in mortgage rates well that
means if you want to purchase a home
it's going to become more unaffordable
for many and sales of existing homes
they're already plummeting new home
construction it's about to come to a
screeching halt fewer and fewer
americans will refinance their homes
property values i know you thought you
could sell your home a year ago for a
lot more money they're about to plummet
with probably notable exceptions states
that may not be hit as hard florida
texas tennessee the carolinas why won't
they be hit as hard because there's a
ton of people leaving deep blue states
like new york and new jersey and
illinois and california and they're
moving to those states so demand will
remain higher what we are seeing is a
complete devolution of the democratic
party that party that is now hell-bent
on decline and destruction and so
addicted to their cult they won't they
they will not even consider changing
course you have a party created
one big far left political cocktail and
that's creating one bad crisis after
another from the washington swamp coast
to coast flyover country city to city
everywhere in between when democrats are
in charge costs go up crime goes up
quality of life goes down and you make
less money just look at the failing far
left d.a out in los angeles this guy
george gascon uh he's now being exposed
yet again as we're now learning the gang
member accused of murdering two police
officers in la county this week oh this
guy has a long rap sheet still out
roaming the streets after be given a
lenient plea bargain by back gaskin's
office last year what was the charge a
weapons charge up in oregon a new
investigation from fox news finds that
the state's effort to decriminalize
drugs has won
has now become one big
unmitigated disaster according to our
very own dan springer 16 months into
this first in the nation experiment the
numbers paint a very bleak picture drug
overdose deaths now hit an all-time high
in 2021
1069 that is a 41 increase from 2020
while reportedly very few people are
seeking treatment so ask yourself why
would any community want to enable
hard drug use you're basically helping
people kill themselves why would any
community want to put the interests of
hard drug users over the safety and
security of ordinary citizens and when
they're high and wasted and out of their
minds they come into contact with uh
people going about their daily chores
now unfortunately in the democratic
playbook law abiding citizens have now
become the enemy common sense americans
are now in the crosshairs of this new
extreme far left socialist democratic
disaster a party that coddles violent
criminals a party that puts illegal
immigrants over americans yeah they get
preferential treatment and a free phone
and you also get free transportation you
get a party that puts far left climate
fantasies over middle class stability a
party that keeps putting america last
under the logic of biden and the
democrats we can't drill more oil here
at home but we can beg saudi arabia iran
venezuela and opec to pump more under
that logic of biden well we can't lower
gas prices now but we can all switch and
buy electric cars overnight it's a
never-ending fight with reality and
facts and basic common sense hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else